i'm just trying to think of like a five
out of ten this is the problem with
trying to
remember a five out of ten anime show is
that uh
i don't remember that's why they're a
five out of ten you know like
the moment
what about manga because you read more
manga because i can remember most five
10 shows it's literally like i go to the
list of isekai i finished and i'm just
like a lot of these are literally 5 out
of 10. even 5 out of 10 manga i'm like i
don't
i just don't remember them and that's
the problem it's like it's so hard to
talk about
these kinds of like mediocre middle of
the ground shows it's because like
unless i recently re-watch it again i'm
not gonna remember it
i'm like oh yeah it's probably something
along those lines but i could wouldn't
be able to like you know concretely tell
you like this is the reason why it's a
five out of ten it's just so like
impactless that it's just like oh i
didn't even know that existed yeah you
know i do feel bad if you feel like
you've wasted a time watching a show no
um
no i feel like when you start caring
that much about the
the media you're the media why sounds
like the media
you know the stuff you're consuming i
feel like
you almost ruined a lot of it for
yourself like stuff that you might have
enjoyed you just think you're worried
too much about if you're enjoying it the
whole time oh that's kind of where i got
to unfortunately with that like it's
like i it got to the point where i was
so selective on what i was watching to
make sure that everything i was watching
was worth my time that if i ran into
something that i was like
well i just wasted an hour because of
watching these first three episodes
great i've i don't know if this is like
i haven't consciously chosen to do this
but i've stopped
scrolling or looking for shows
yeah it's just kind of whatever appears
in front whatever whatever is
recommended whatever is put in my head
or i think that's the best way to
consume media and honestly i've been
having a great time i i feel like i
honestly wish i honestly wish i could do
that because
it's not even anime it's like pretty
much every form of media and it's not
even about
me like being like a [ __ ] snob
wanting to like consume the best [ __ ] um
it's literally i started really caring
about it when i just didn't have the
time
to do everything i wanted to do right so
like nowadays like even even if it's
just like picking a game i want it to be
a game i could probably get into like i
don't i don't know what we are stuck in
this cycle of constantly worrying if the
game is good enough for your time and
then you know you'll never start yeah
you never [ __ ] play anything exactly
yeah yeah i mean that's what i feel
games are way more of a time sink than
an anime
on average yeah i mean i mean it depends
well like to me getting into a game
getting like properly absorbed into a
game is just like it's one of the most
magical experiences and i [ __ ] love
it when i just get absorbed into a video
game world it's the same way that i get
absorbed into an anime or absorbed into
a manga or something like that
absolutely and like to me i don't know
like because my time is so precious to
me right now i'm
it sucks that i i like constantly have
to like have this little part of my head
that's just like oh could you be
watching something better that you do
enjoy maybe a little bit more no are you
really in the mood for this yeah
optimize your schedule in every way
right yeah so i feel like the stuff that
you consume should be the one thing
where you're like no pressure like
whatever you watch whatever you play
doesn't matter if it wasn't the game of
the year doesn't matter if it wasn't the
movie of the year yeah just watch
whatever comes up so i have an opinion
on it like i watch that uh don't look up
oh yeah yeah what a [ __ ] movie uh what
an awful movie that was a five out of
ten i hated that
you hated that i hated it
a lot of people hated it [ __ ] bought
and it went on for like an hour longer
than it needed to right and like yeah
there were some funny moments of it
there were some bits that i chuckled but
overall i just felt like i i wasted my
time yeah but
i was like i'm glad i watched this
because it gave me even though i i i
came out
disliking the movie for some reason that
made me happy i was like yeah that was
[ __ ] and it was fun getting to talk to
other people who also thought it was
[ __ ] i don't know i just liked it i
think as well it's because like even
even if you do consume something that is
[ __ ] within that like specific medium
like it just broadens your horizon more
on the medium and like it adds to the
knowledge pool of like oh now that i've
consumed something on the other side of
the spectrum now i'm i'm a little bit
more knowledgeable about what makes the
good [ __ ] good right yeah i'm definitely
like that with music where i'm like if
it's on [ __ ] spotify i'm just
listening to it right right like i i
watched um as well i watched uh
spider-man movie the new one oh yeah
yeah and like yeah it was great but i
because it was just great and i had a
good time
my emotions are way stronger about don't
look up right really i i hated it right
yeah you had more to talk about yeah i
have more i watched i watched no way
home and i had a great time but at the
end of the day i've already like
forgotten about it and i don't care and
it was yeah it was good but it was just
that was a movie i [ __ ] loved i was i
liked it a lot but i just i'm after i'm
done with it i'm like that was
everything i expected it to be right and
i had fun but i don't feel strongly
about it i think that's the thing though
it's like the the problem is like i
think the sweet spot of like
you being able to like really gush out
about something is like when it's on two
or the two ends of the spectrum right
where it's either like so [ __ ]
incredible like 10 out of 10 masterpiece
where you can just gush about your love
for it forever and then there's the
other side where it's like let me tell
you about how absolutely atrocious this
[ __ ] yeah dude i watched um uh could you
google this for me actually it's uh
robert pattinson's movie uh i forgot the
name [ __ ] i watched it like three weeks
ago
no no no no it's been a five out of ten
yeah yeah right right it must have been
a fight that's amazing
oh yeah
that's just him is it good time good
times
it kind of remembers [ __ ] things i know
to forget things apparently
good time yeah dude good time please
[ __ ] watch a good time it's so good
this movie was amazing
i want you to watch it so badly so we
can talk about it because yeah it's
what's it about i don't want to say
anything but go into it have you watched
uncut gems
yeah you know like how it's just anxiety
simulator yeah it's it's that and and
like right it is literally like anxiety
simulation okay it's so good it's
amazing and it's just like a movie that
when you watch it i just felt like
this was just i'm so glad i watched this
movie like i just felt like i had like
experienced something special that a lot
of love and care went into and that
everyone really just brought their a
game like it was just amazing please
watch it it's so good a lot of roblox
yeah yeah so
again go and watch it it's really good
um i absolutely adore all of his stuff i
think he's really good in a lot of
things i'm really hyped for him as
batman i'm hyped for him
yeah every movie i've watched with him
after twilight he chose weird-ass roles
that were just so good and just nailed
it but that's that's what i love about
like that's what i love about actors
like that though because daniel
radcliffe did the exact same thing right
it's like usually those like super
popular type casted characters who are
like
now people are just going to know me as
this [ __ ] forever so i'm just going to
go into all the like all the way
like all the weird artsy like daniel
radcliffe movies like i've seen so many
of them and they're just like
man like [ __ ] respects dude like you
can do [ __ ] later now he's like doing
broadway [ __ ] yeah he's doing that right
it's [ __ ] great like he's like yeah
good on you i feel like that like actors
going weird and doing weird films is
like the actual equivalent of the
youtuber gave him the hair dye
it's like guys i want an image change
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna do a bunch
of weird [ __ ] now right
sure because they've all gone on like
shia labeouf as well
all the weird [ __ ] afterwards as well
which one do you do uh nymph
informaniac [ __ ] that was a weird watch
yeah watch that go on no i won't got to
watch this
it's uh what's the [ __ ] uh director's
name he's it's like the really
like maniac is right
it's you know that's a three-parter yeah
yeah it's a three-part it's a trillion
no no it's two parts
last one yeah it's a lot of one trick
four parts right two yeah it's two
yeah yeah two volume and two yeah no no
no not of nymphomaniac like of that
universe oh no the one with the shadow
buff movies are two yeah i watched it
it's a universe no a lot there's like a
tree it's like a trilogy of las vegas
movies and nympha maniac i think is the
third one
you should
i've seen all the lives of entrepreneur
movies and nymphomaniacs easily the
[ __ ] weirdest one and i was like oh
charlotte buffs it's like you just go
what the [ __ ] you just go from even
stevens like shut up sis and it's like
oh gosh oh god oh goodness
i didn't i didn't i didn't wish to see
sharla bluff's butthole in three
different scenes but there it is i guess
i didn't mean to watch this movie it
came on the tv yeah where did you how
did you see it it was on tv i was i was
on tv uh i was in a hotel and like isn't
it like an x-rated movie i think i said
like bulgaria and it was on tv or
something
you watched it
i i know i watched it i watched it in a
european country and it was on tv at
like 2 a.m and i couldn't sleep and i
was rushed and just i remember just
thinking like what the [ __ ] also felt
like a [ __ ] fever dream it was yeah
it was weird that yeah anything lost one
tram makes is a [ __ ] fever tree it's
weird